Disney's one of the biggest film studios
on the planet and it's no secret that a
role in one of their family-friendly
blockbusters can make an active career
however not everyone's eager to work
with the mouse house and there are a
number of stars who have actually
refused to major roles in big Disney
movies and shows and Hathaway although
she did end up in the movie and Hathaway
actually had the opportunity to take the
lead role in Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland the actress turned it down
because she felt she had already played
a very similar princess and address type
role and the Princess Diaries
however Hathaway told the studio should
be willing to play the White Queen
instead and that's what she did it ended
up being a good decision as Hathaway
took home some awards for her turn as
the White Queen and opens up the door
for newcomer Mia boshy Cove scre to take
on the role of Alice warren beatty
Gilbert Gottfried's Yago provided the
comic relief in Disney's Aladdin always
chiming in with a squawk or a screech to
lighten the mood during some of the
film's more intense moments o Jafar
you're too kind I'm in Paris however
according to the actor he almost didn't
get the chance to play the iconic role
Godfried revealed in his memoir that in
order to lunge the part he had to be
told Joe Pesci and Danny DeVito
apparently the role was actually offered
to the star of the 2017 Oscars Best
Picture mixer Warren Beatty Beatty
reportedly turned down the role because
playing a parrot in the desert felt too
similar to his role from Ishtar
just imagine how different the film
would have been without Godfrey's iconic
squawk Jaden wait Billy Crystal Toy
Story is one of the most iconic films of
all time with a hundred percent critical
rating on Rotten Tomatoes while Tim
Allen's work as Buzz Lightyear is
classic it turns out that the character
was nearly brought to life by a
different actor Billy Crystal who would
become famous with Disney Pixar fans the
voicing Mike Wazowski in monsters Inc
was offered the part in the early
planning stages of the film apparently
Pixar was so eager to get him to sign on
that's the studio actually animated an
early version of Buzz Lightyear with
some dialogue from When Harry Met Sally
the result is
interesting see everyone is in love and
that's wonderful but you got to know
that someday believe it or not there
were 15 rounds of a who's going to get
this coffee table as we all know now
crystal turned it down and Tim Allen got
the putt while crystal has had a great
career he told ABC News in 2001 that's
passing on buzzers actually something he
regrets interestingly the Pixar movie
crystal did appear in almost had a
totally different co-star to Bill Murray
in 2001 monsters Inc became an instant
classic for Disney and Pixar fans
the film won an Oscar and earned further
accolades for each of its two main leads
Billy Crystal and John Goodman but
Goodman who famously voiced Sully almost
didn't get the part
director Pete docter stop choice for the
part was actually legendary comedian
Bill Murray the actor screen tested for
the part and impressed doctor but when
he called to offer him the part he
couldn't get Murray to pick up the phone
the director of another Murray movie his
st. Vincent explained just how difficult
it is to track the guy down just to
offer him work the job of Bill Murray is
really finding Bill Murray which
everyone knows once you find Bill Murray
then the job kind of goes downhill
Murray is notoriously hard to reach so
it's still unclear if this was his way
of saying he wasn't interested or it was
just a miscommunication either way you
won't hear any complaints about it from
John Goodman Leonardo DiCaprio hocus
pocus may not have been the biggest
dizzy film of all time but the movie has
a huge cult following and is still the
subject of many a Halloween movie
marathon the filmmakers were especially
picky about searching for their star and
they eventually narrowed it down to the
venn up-and-comer Leonardo DiCaprio to
play max despite being offered some
serious coin DiCaprio turned down the
pass because he wanted to wait and see
if it land the role in What's Eating
Gilbert Grape
though it was likely terrifying at the
time the Caprio had said that this was
the best and toughest decision he has
ever made it definitely worked out for
him as Leo earned his first Academy
Award nomination for What's Eating
Gilbert Grape and have been an a-lister
ever since Omri cats who eventually took
the role of Max and hocus-pocus
stops acting in 2002
Lily Tomlin well it's hard to imagine
anything different in the Pixar classic
The Incredibles one of the film's
signature characters was almost voiced
by someone else Edna mode the superhero
stylist who really really hate capes was
voiced by director Brad Bird in the
final product
nut case however that's not what he'd
intended
apparently when bird recorded the voice
for Edna he was just filling in for
actress Lily Tomlin who was set to play
the part however when she heard birds
take on the character she decided that
it wasn't something she could improve on
you know you've made it in show business
when you can pass on a Disney movie
paycheck and not bat an eye Michael
Douglas in 2013 frozen became a
commercial and critical success bringing
in over 1.3 billion dollars and winning
two Academy Awards the voice acting in
the movie was great but the casting
might have turned out differently
Michael Douglas told a James Corden that
he turned down a part in the film but
couldn't remember exactly which role
from oh no you will want to play Elsa I
don't remember
although we don't know for sure our best
guess is that Douglas was offered either
the Duke of weselton Hans or Kristoff
although it would be funny it's probably
dull for that service was ever in line
to voice Olaf Selena Gomez it's no
secret that for many years Selena Gomez
was one of the Queen's of the Disney
Channel Network what's surprising though
is that Gomez actually ended up turning
down the lead role of Mickey in Camp
Rock because she wanted to do more
conventional and serious acting before
ultimately transitioning into a more
music focused career gomez also
reportedly turned down an undisclosed
part in high school musical three senior
year for similar reasons these days
Selena is one of the most successful pop
stars around but we have to wonder just
how much our serious acting role in
Spring Breakers really helps her cause
Jack Nicholson Hercules is an animated
Disney classic and the bust in large
part thanks to James Wood smooth-talking
Hades
leave my fate is in your lovely hand
however the path was apparently written
with Jack Nicholson specifically in mind
and the studio tried their best to land
him for the role well Jack likes the
creative side of the deal he and Disney
were unable to agree on the business end
of things so he ended up walking away
from the role after testing actors like
Robert Evans and John Lithgow the
filmmakers landed on woods and the rest
is history
could it be his great Hercules
performance that from did Seth
MacFarlane strange obsession with James
Woods James Woods has you and I have
James Woods - thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]